foreign
situation in my marriage I like fell
back into porn try to explain it to her
I was like I don't know why you know I'm
just this little rubber band and I keep
snapping back and like trying to cut it
I'm absolutely terrified of falling back
I know but not terrified enough to do
something you're just sitting there
being terrified
[Music]
John alone he's showing why are we
yelling I don't know just a good day
having a good day hope you're having a
good day wherever you happen to be
you've survived Thanksgiving and you're
a few weeks out from Christmas and hey
let's be super realistic for some of you
this is the your favorite time of the
year it's incredible some of you this is
not this is a really tough season you
are
um
you looked over and saw an empty seat at
the Thanksgiving table and you are
anticipating there being a few Christmas
presents few are under the tree because
someone you love is not there anymore
um or you have to deal with in-laws or
family or parents or whoever that have
caused you a lot of grief
wherever you happen to be don't forget
you're worth taking care of this holiday
season you're worth
laughing you're worth having boundaries
and taking care of yourself take care of
yourself take care of yourself okay make
sure you love yourself during this
holiday season and honestly the best way
we can love ourselves during the season
is to make sure we got friends around us
make sure we are serving other people
make sure we're taking care of our
bodies like sleeping eating right moving
even though it's freezing outside
do those things get in sunlight when you
can
take care of yourself take care of
yourself and if this is your favorite
time of year Well Philly on you I'm just
kidding I love it too all right hey
um I had a note let me pull up my my
internet papers here
internet papers is that a thing I don't
think that's a thing I think those are
Polar Opposites I think the internet
came to replace paper
um way to go internets so I gotta uh uh
some guy's wife Laura slid into my DMs
and she said I said that bad I said
about you to stop saying that I said it
bad I didn't mean to I mean I meant to
say it but I didn't mean it to be Grody
but it did make me laugh so this
incredible listener
um sent me a direct message on
Instagrams and
um she said her husband is made some
incredible life changes but big fan of
the show and um that they read on your
passenger future together and that he is
making some major break this cycle
changes and she wanted to know if I
would be able to autograph a book and
send it for Christmas
and I said yes and let's let's
um one-up that let's give this dude a
call and um so I'm gonna give him a buzz
I'm gonna give David a call so uh hang
on one second I'm gonna dial the number
up
what if he doesn't answer
David
hey David
yes this is John from the Dr John
deloney show man what are you doing
are you kidding me no man this is me
what are you doing
dude I'm working
I'm doing that oh cause it's Monday
that's why it's a good idea hey are
things going well
oh dude they're going amazing Hey so uh
this is kind of tripping you out and I
know that so I haven't used your last
name and I'm recording this you can tell
me off air hey you can't use this but
okay here's what I want to let you know
your wife reached out and she's awesome
and in a nutshell she said
that you have been on a journey the last
few years and have been about breaking
some major Cycles in that she's so
freaking proud of you
and she asked um she asked if I would
send an autographed book she want to
give to you for Christmas and so I was
like absolutely but more than that I
wanted to just to talk to a fellow guy
who's trying to figure it out like me
and
um let you know that I'm really grateful
to know there's guys like you out there
grinding it and determined to make what
comes next better than what happened in
the past and
um I just want to give you a shout out
dude and tell you I love you and I'm
grateful for you man oh my word are you
kidding me thank you so much man so tell
me about what you've been what you've
been working on
I've been working on trying to change my
family tree sir what does that mean
um
just
just being present just
just
making a decision and like you said and
like you advise giving myself Grace to
practice it
what's that what's the what's probably
the number one thing you're working on
practicing right now
that I need to be whole
to be a good husband
that I need to take care of me and it's
okay to take care of yourself
and I do it by not comparing myself to
others but to kept comparing myself to
who I was yesterday
oh dude that's amazing and you married
well you did good
oh my word I married a amazing
red-headed beautiful Midwest scale
and then you drug her to California man
what are you doing
yeah I think uh it hit us when we parked
the U-Haul in California and we looked
at each other
you know as you would say not
not by my hand but in my life there you
go there's a great song by one of my
favorite bands ever Social Distortion
called Bakersfield you should check it
out
um okay the whole song is about wanting
to get home and we're stuck in
Bakersfield and it just seems to never
end but terrible listing in Bakersfield
we love you it's cool it's a great
farming Community there in uh in uh
California but hey in all seriousness
I'm I'm truly grateful for you I want
you to hang on the line so that Jenna
can get your info and I'll send you and
uh Laura some stuff
um just as a gift just for saying thank
you for being one of those those men in
the world who are making some changes is
that awesome appreciate that you guys
gonna have a good holiday season
oh man we're gonna have a great holiday
season and sir I'm gonna send you an
email to keep me accountable because I'm
trying to do a Half Marathon this year
or early May dude got a boy man get on
it then yes sir hey we'll uh we'll post
your picture when you cross the finish
line is that cool
but hey we're gonna have Laura's gonna
send a picture of you just eating nachos
on the couch if you don't end up running
okay either way a picture of you is
getting posted you get to pick which one
it is all right but hey I'm grateful for
you my man and um thanks for uh letting
us shout you out on the air here it's
awesome this is David from California
and his awesome wife Laura who didn't
slide into my DM she just sent me a
message
um breaking the cycle changes it's
incredible and hey
um
right now at John deloney.com own your
past change your future
um redefining anxiety all the questions
for humans cards man
um they are on super sale for the
holidays go pick them up if you've got
some books you want to pass out to some
of your friends and family over
Christmas that's fantastic if you want
to learn how to talk to your kids again
or people at work or you just want to
survive the holidays without talking
about covet and the elections
ah jeez hey go over to John deloney.com
and pick those things up all right let's
go to Patrick in Salem
Virginia what's up Patrick
hey John thank you for having me on you
got it man thanks for hanging out you
get to you get to see how the sausages
made if you if you call into the show
and just we put you on hold for a while
or we I think we called you and put you
on hold for a while you get to hear what
a disaster I am behind the scenes right
oh it's all good thank you thank
goodness for editing right oh you have
no idea man you have no idea
um so what's up
um so my question is um how do I have a
healthy relationship with work
and uh there's a kind of a long
backstory to that that we can kind of
dig through a little bit but uh long
story short I tend to get into this
cycle where I'm super excited about a
job I love the new career opportunity
and then like
six months into it I'm like yeah this is
awful I don't like this anymore and then
I get burned out
um
frustrated and then I I tap out and
leave
um I'm really tired of that cycle and I
wanna break out of it but I don't really
know how oh man
how old are you
I'm 26.
okay
this is one of those rare moments in my
life when I get to talk to 26 year old
me
okay
and I have
oh my gosh man I can get pretty
emotional about this
um
I'm gonna give you like a conversation
direct from my heart is that cool
yep that works for me because I'm
talking to myself at 26.
26 is when I got my
um first big fancy job at a university
and I think it was three or four months
in then I started applying for another
job and then for another one and then
for another one and then I got so
obsessed with applying for other jobs
and then I finally got one
and then I got there and within five to
six months I was already applying for
something else and then I was looking
for something else I was looking for
something else right and then I ended up
imploding
in counseling we call it the tyranny of
accomplishing all of your dreams
foreign
is you were looking for somewhere
something
to make you feel like you are worth
being alive and that thing doesn't exist
whether that's a new romantic partner
well that's a new car whether it's a new
job
and you show up with the best of
intentions because this is going to be
the one and you get after it and you
realize right when you get there that
you went with you
right yeah yep and you get bored and you
get annoyed
and so tell me if I'm wrong here and man
feel free to tell me I'm wrong here was
my special gift you ready
I would get bored
I would not not bored that's not right I
would get disillusioned
I thought it would feel different making
x amount of dollars I thought it would
feel different having such and such
title I thought it would feel different
having these type of meetings or being
included at this level instead of that
level right yep and so what I would do
is
I would begin to slowly make the people
around me my enemy
and I would get annoyed by their jokes
that weren't very funny or I would find
one little place where I thought I
wouldn't handle it like that I would do
it like this or if there was I wouldn't
say a moral black and white failure
there's all obviously those but they're
Gray
and I would make the gray super black
and white so that I could begin to
create space giving me permission to
leave with my head held high because I
am this martyr here making this big
right decision and I'm out of here and
I'm going to the next thing
yep you must have had somebody following
me for the last six years because that's
pretty much exactly it no I'm just
recounting my life I'm recounting my
life
so
there's a couple of things to at play
here but
ultimately it starts with an identity
shift
okay here's a couple of the major
identity shifts I'm gonna make one of
them came from a mentor of mine
um I consider him one of the smartest
most brilliant wise Minds I've ever had
the opportunity to be in contact with
and to use a I'd consider him a
spiritual Mentor he's someone I have
gone to in the past for a quandaries
about ethical and moral decisions in my
life
he posed this question one time and it
was it was kind of like a dagger to me
he said what if you lived your life like
you would never move
like you couldn't ever move
what conversations would you have then
what um
what would you do to improve the
relationships in your life what would
you do to change the way you presented
yourself at work and in your marriage
and in your neighborhood
because if we are at your church right
because if it's always like I don't like
it I'm out of here
um then we are never going to be settled
and so when I took this job my current
one I made a choice I'm gonna be here
and so I can honestly say for the first
time in my life I have not applied for
another job since I've been here
okay right it's a choice I mean it's an
identity I'm gonna be here now there may
come a day when I gotta go or I get more
likely I get asked to leave
um but
I am I am going to put both of my feet
here and what that's meant is I've had
to seek validation
seek well-being seek Wellness elsewhere
that means that I've had to make peace
with me and that has sucked and that has
meant I've had to have some very
difficult and challenging conversations
with my wife
I've had to become a different Dad I've
had to go to counseling I've had a coach
that I've met with regularly just to
walk through different decisions and
thought processes
I've had to really become laser
disciplined with my exercise and diet
I've had to do a lot of internal work
and make some major changes in my life
um I've had to really get serious about
my spiritual life I've had to just make
some internal changes because I'm not
relying on some external job to try to
make me whole because it can't do that
does that make sense that makes perfect
sense so what job are you doing right
now
um So currently I'm a package handler
for uh for FedEx okay and um tomorrow I
start orientation for a checker position
at a Coca-Cola oh so you've already quit
that job and you're on to the next
um it's it's a part-time job so it's not
paying me enough to uh to pay the
mortgage so I gotta yeah do something
else
um
are you married so yeah I'm I am married
yes you have little ones uh no kids yet
has your wife started getting that
exhale when you come home with a new
scheme or a new plan or a new reason why
you got to leave this job
oh we haven't hit that point yet with
this job
um no no I'm talking about she's been
with you for six years oh yeah yeah no
that was a kind of a big big
conversation we were having about a year
and a half ago let me tell you why
that's devastating this is devastating
to her I don't want to guilty or shame
you but I just want to paint you a
bigger picture because right now all
you're doing is staring at your belly
button and I know because I was there
she's also wondering what about me
when does he wake up and get bored with
me
when does he wake up and decide he needs
another one of me too
and if you're being honest
you've had that thought as well
and she can feel it on you
foreign
okay I'll give you that one but you know
um
I didn't realize
how unsettled how every time my wife
started to put roots in the ground I
would cut I would sever them
and for me looking for another job
looking for another place looking for
another opportunity with sport
for her it was just ripping the plant
out of the pot again ripping the plant
out of the pot again I didn't realize
how hard her heart was pumping every day
just to try to have some semblance of
normalcy because she didn't know where
her flighty
flaky husband was gonna drag her off to
next
either emotionally or spiritually or
actually like let's move this from this
city and go somewhere else
and so
that same thing I'm putting out on on
your wife that I did to my wife
it's happening to you too
and so the first thing what you do is to
resettle your identity I'm going to be a
guy who sticks around
I'm going to be a guy that uses that all
that energy to I'm out of here I'm
looking for a new job I'm going to use
that energy to be the best freaking
employee in this whole company
I'm going to work to satisfy this
Mission and try that for six months
go all in this company went all in on
you go all in back give them that much
dignity and respect for six months
see if it doesn't change your entire
well-being and
if you've created a life for yourself
that you can't afford whether it's a
mortgage whether it's car payments
whether it's whatever it is your body is
going to respond anxiously all of the
time and you're going to be trying to
solve that anxiety everywhere have you
done that
yeah I I get into that um I get into
those thought processes and it's like oh
I can start this business or I'm like
constantly looking for stuff on the side
of the road that I can pick up and sell
for 20 bucks and but is that because
you've created a life for yourself that
you can't afford
we we can afford our um our lifestyle uh
the the mortgage is really the only debt
that we have I'm still paying off a
little bit of school from when I got my
my CDL license
um but as far as like we're going to
lose everything in the next 30 days if I
don't get a paycheck um it's not quite
to that point
okay that means your body is running hot
right now trying to keep you guys safe
so I want you to hang on the line I'm
going to send you for free one year of
Ramsay plus that's my parent company
that's the where I work here and we're
gonna I'm gonna give you all the lessons
to pay off all those debts but more
importantly to give you and your wife an
Avenue for conversation about who you're
going to be as a couple how you're going
to spend money how you're going to
budget how you're going to work together
and
that when you when you go through a
process just how are we going to spend
our money
how are we going to join bank accounts
if you haven't done that already that
happens today
how do we become one in this deal then
you have to start planning about what
tomorrow looks like when you start
planning about what tomorrow looks like
you have to decide things like what job
are you going to do and where are you
going to work and who do you want to be
what do you want to do does that make
sense
yep that makes perfect you guys got to
have those conversations your wife
deserves some stability man and you do
too yeah
and
what's your long-term play man what do
you want to do what were you what what's
your purpose who do you want to serve
oh ultimately I want to serve my Creator
and my savior
um that's my number one goal but what
does that look like as a job
I have not a clue I've done I worked in
the golf industry as a golf professional
I've worked as a Mason I've worked as an
electrician I was a truck driver I've
been all over the map and
I barely know which way is up and in
regards to a career Okay and like I'm
just trying to pay the bills right now
that's right that's right
what's underneath that
a lot of fear a fear of what
not being good enough
who told you that
I don't know who told me you do who was
it say it out loud
it's kind of crazy to say but my
kindergarten teacher it was kind of a
the first person that ever even planted
that thought in my head and I've just
been repeating it over and over for the
last 21 years how did Mom and Dad
contribute to that
foreign
and I never really felt celebrated for
the little Winds of getting better at
something okay
as a kid you should have got that
and I'm not saying your dad's a bad guy
I'm saying your dad did no no he's not
he didn't have that tool in his tool kit
and my guess is he was trying to push
you because he wanted you to become a
great man and often men pushing other
men to become great men forget that you
can only become great
when the bottom rungs of the needs the
hierarchy of needs are met which are
safety and relationships right then you
when you are anchored in there's a
reason they send you to boot camp
um and are in the Army in the military
so that you can learn to follow rules
and you learn to work as a team because
only then can you go do great things
right yeah
so those things happened and here you
are
now you're gonna have to decide to do is
to get a group of guys are you lonely as
I'll get out too
yeah yeah um yep yep so
you have to make a conscious Choice I'm
ending I'm gonna stop being lonely
I'm gonna get with a group of guys
whether I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
invite a group of randos out from work
from my church from the neighborhood I
don't care
I'm have a barbecue at my house and
everyone's just gonna be invited over I
don't care how this looks you're gonna
have to get radical about that the same
as people get about losing weight same
as they get about exercise programs is
quitting drinking you're gonna have to
decide to quit being lonely
with a radical move okay
and I want you and your wife to sit down
and say and I want you to tell her I
understand that I have given you a life
that lacks stability
and my promise is I'm gonna start
working to heal from the inside out not
from the outside
and you are probably gonna see her
exhaling away you haven't seen in a long
time because here's what I guarantee
she's done she's created a cocoon of a
world for her to exist in where it's
safe because you're not
and your body senses that you are not
connected and it is trying to solve that
because it is anxious anxious anxious
anxious anxious
right yeah that's yeah that's spot on
okay so we're gonna we're going to
take a knee
this is submission and all you by the
way pause real quick here Patrick all
you idiots out there who are like what
here is a simp or whatever that's
supposed to be shut up shut up
some of the most bold
masculine things you can do is to take a
knee in front of your wife and say I've
screwed this up or I've been trying to
solve this problem this way and it's not
working and I've left you completely
isolated alone I'm sorry
I'm committed to learning new skills
and skill number one is I'm going to
learn to be at peace with myself skill
number one two is I'm going to learn to
learn to live in stability I've never
had it before
is that cool Patrick yep that that
sounds good okay also I want you to stay
on the line my friend Ken Coleman who is
a career Guru has a career assessment
I'm gonna send it to you for free I'm
gonna send you a code online I want you
to take it okay oh I actually I actually
did take that um
okay and um did it help yeah
it did help
um it helped clarify some of the the
underlying frustrations that I've found
with okay those particular jobs very
cool well then I'll do this I'll send
you I'm gonna send you a copy of
paycheck to purpose his book and I want
you to read through that and also send
you his other book too I'm sending you
everything
um proximity principle and that will
walk you through here's where we go next
but that is for you to read and Ponder
and read with your wife and get some
feedback get some friends who will speak
into your life before I took this job I
flew to Texas and met with some of my
oldest friends in the world because I I
get I get emotional I get anxious I get
wound up
and a good leader which is I'm trying to
lead a business I'm trying to lead my
units I'm trying to lead my family
um or co-lead my family with my wife
like a good leader takes feedback and
wisdom especially in the fog of War I
flew to Texas met with some friends and
I asked them hey I've been working for
20 years to get to this one one place in
my career and I finally got there I'm
thinking about quitting it to go be a
YouTuber
and I took their wisdom and they all
laughed and smiled and opened a drink
and we talked and cracked up and then
they said hey this sounds crazy and this
sounds right
and that's what I needed I needed some
perspective and some sobriety
not literal sobriety but sobriety so
once you get some friends and have those
conversations about work and purpose and
value
but you're not going to find it man
someone's going to bring you in and pay
you a million dollars
and call you CEO
and you're still gonna look in the
mirror and see that Kindergarten kid
whose teacher said you'll never amount
to crap
or you'll still see that seventh grader
who gets so excited that you got an 88
on that math test that you busted your
butt for and your dad says wow would
have killed you to get two more points
you could get an A
are always just gonna be a b student
until you let that kid be free kid's
gonna be trying to solve the problems
man
and money and titles won't fix them
[Music]
start with your home start with your
wife throw your relationship start with
y'all's identity
start with you deciding you want to be
well
and man you got a whole Runway ahead of
you
into a radical new life it's going to be
incredible we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we are back let's go to Amanda
in Madison Wisconsin what's up Amanda
hi John how are you today I'm good how
are you
hi I'm piano I'm I'm living the dream
right
hey I'm running I'm running a scam they
call a podcast here so I can't really
talk I'm having fun so what's up
the reason I'm calling you today is
because I'm trying to figure out how to
help best my son or how to best help my
son who is um he's a sixth grader first
you know first year in middle school and
he's experiencing something like on
bouts of on and off anxiety to the point
where it's like manifesting in physical
like headaches and feeling sick and
things like that where he's having a
hard time
giving through his day and
I'm trying to figure out how to help him
get through these these things that he's
going through is this new or has this
been going on a long time
it has been
Gummer he really wanted to play tackle
football with his friends
and we got him into that and after a
couple of weeks he was getting
um
physical like hip pains or back pains
where he felt like he couldn't practice
he was couldn't play in football then
you know so I'd take him to practice to
let him watch and learn still but then
the coaches were saying that he was you
know screwing around or playing on
playing around on the sidelines and and
doing things that if he's you know he's
not appearing to be actually hurt
um and so then I was able to figure out
from him after some conversations that
he was scared about getting tackled and
getting hurt at football practice and we
were able to then work through those
issues with the coaches and you know
with some extra time with the coaches he
was able to work through that and finish
the season but
yeah so that's another instance where he
had like I don't know if that was
anxiety or if it was just fear or if it
I don't
I
I don't see a lot of utility in trying
to parse the difference
okay
um whether it's fear or anxiety and what
type of anxiety it is
um sometimes it's helpful to name the
dragon but generally speaking your son's
body is telling him
to opt out of a situation
and it has determined that going to
school is not a safe situation it's
determined that playing football is not
a safe situation and since he doesn't
seem to be able to get the signals it's
going to start manifesting pain and hurt
and all kinds of things that have a
weird self-reinforcement to them because
that's when people lean in and say are
you okay
and they listen to them and they hear
him and his body goes oh thank God and
I'm seen and I'm heard finally and then
it reinforces okay that's how we get
that sort of connection there
so backing out
um these are always hard questions and
they're not supposed to be accusatory
okay this is just data collection do you
and your husband have anxious Tendencies
to like where is
where is this anxiety coming from did he
get hurt somewhere did he watch one of
his football friends just get leveled is
he getting bullied at school where does
this originate from
I
I don't personally suffer from any like
anxious Tendencies my husband does okay
um he did see one of his teammates get
hurt at football practice and that kind
of I think where some of that stems from
sure at school he was diagnosed last
year with dyslexia okay
um and so he struggles with keeping
things straight in his mind and gets
overwhelmed when he because they use
Google classroom and so he can see all
the different assignments that they're
going to work on for that given day and
then he sees how many he's got and then
he gets overwhelmed of oh my gosh I have
so much to do well but also with
dyslexia
he gets a reinforcement on a daily basis
that he's stupid
and that he's and that he's different he
does I bet he does
one of the most common responses I've
had with young working with young people
with dyslexia is a reinforcement that
everybody's going faster than they are
and that it's become something's wrong
with them
and it's a message that schools pass
along not unintentionally maybe not with
your particular sub man I've just heard
that over and over yeah
and that was something that I worried
about getting you know because I had him
assessed for some you know just because
I knew he was struggling and I wanted to
know why I wanted to know what it was
and I wanted to know how to help him and
the dyslexia diagnosis was at least
something to be like okay now let's how
do we work around this and it hasn't
been anything
that
I've noticed that he he's he's been able
to really adapt to it and work around it
but he's not he's not his body's not
this isn't an intellectual exercise his
body is telling him he's not okay
let me ask you this what you need to get
him into a there
what's your what's your husband's
avoidance strategies when he gets
anxious how does he get out of
situations
um
he he when he does when he's
uncomfortable he pretty much just quit
so he exits the building
yeah okay children are unable to do that
because they don't have car keys they
don't have control they don't have
autonomy
and so kids bodies revolt
does that make sense
so I just want you to think of your son
as a little boy
whose body is telling him he's not safe
and he can't leave
and I'm not saying to run and leave okay
right so
let me back out this way the first thing
I want you to do is I want you to
believe him
okay
believe him that he hurts understand
that
um some folks have really tall kids some
folks have short kids some folks have
kids with lots my friends used to make
call me guaca when I was a kid because I
had lots of moles right some like
whatever dude like there's all kinds of
things that parents like their kids are
born with you your kid might have a
a heightened a heightened sensitivity in
his amygdala that doesn't mean he's
sensitive and he not like that just his
body experiences things in an amplified
way particularly anxiety that's it right
his amygdala is Uber reactive that's all
okay so what we're going to teach him
over a period of time is
when that system goes off and says
you're not safe
every kid watched their buddy get
smashed on that football field
your kid's alarm system was just louder
than theirs does that make sense
so what we're going to do is we're going
to teach them both and
and it's going to be really tough
because his brain has to learn that this
is the alarm system and we can do it
anyway
and not only can we do it anyway but on
the other side of doing it and
accomplishing it and and getting these
little wins
it's going to feel infinitely better
than the cheap winds we're getting every
time we avoid something
accomplishment is going to feel better
than this headache does that make sense
yes and so
what does care look like in your home or
let me ask this direct do you all have
special time where you have one-on-one
time where there's 30 minutes and
there's no phone and you ask him how his
day went you'll color together you'll
draw all together you'll do Legos
together do you have any type of system
like that
we typically on the weekends will do
like family game night or something like
that I mean it's not an every we don't
get time every day to do something but
we usually on the weekends are able to
set some time and do family game night
okay so there's this it's out of the
conscious discipline literature but it's
called two good choices and we're going
to teach this young man some autonomy
but it's going to be bound at autonomy
meaning you're going to give him a
couple of ideas
and I want you to and your husband to
make some schedule some time in your
schedule three times a week not
including the weekends
it could be breakfast time I take my son
to breakfast once a week is it
convenient no do I have time for it
really no
it's become one of my favorite moments
of my life
and sometimes we only get 30 minutes at
Waffle House I get 30 minutes of time
with him and diabetes but we go right we
do it every every once a week
but I want y'all to pencil in 30 minutes
where there's no phones there's no
screens there is nothing but connection
and I want you to give him you want to
do Legos together or do you want to do
fill in the blank together
and he gets to pick which one of those
things he gets to enter into
and you're not going to try to solve
anything you're not going to try to
coach him on anything you're just going
to practice being with
and my guess is it's a crazy guess but
my guess is over time his body's going
to
oh I don't know how that I didn't know
how that felt that feels really good
I like this relationship connectivity
does that make sense
and
in the meantime if he doesn't want to
play football that's fine
um my friend Lane Norton just won World
Championships in weightlifting if him
and I were working out together and he
lifted his reps and I got under the bar
I'd have to take a lot of weight off
because I'm just not that strong yet
yeah like I did that I'll never be as
strong as it is Lane
um but I would have to take some weight
off because I'm not there yet I'm
practicing training
and similarly he's in sixth grade he's
got a potentially a very reactive
amygdala great if he comes home and says
whoa I just saw one of my classmates get
depleted
and his nose got broken and I don't
really want to play football anymore say
okay
you have to choose because we're going
to do one outdoor thing
you got to pick one thing
and you can choose from soccer or
baseball but you're going to do a thing
but you don't have to play football and
we're not cashing out we're not wimping
out we're not he's got to choose another
activity he can't just go home and play
video games or whatever but we're going
to slowly teach him that okay
you're learning we're going to practice
something else then and we're just going
to do that with if he gets an 88 that's
fine for now right what is he nervous
about at school
um like what's the failure he's sensing
there why is his body not want him in
that building
I haven't been able to really pinpoint I
think it's just the whole the
overwhelmed because he
was for real now on classes like he can
get
he can get enough he can fail stuff or
like um yeah but where does he get the
sense that a failure is the end of
something
is that from you and your husband is I
put a lot of pressure on my kids to do
well academically so I'm not saying it's
a bad thing except from y'all is it from
school where is it from
I mean we we don't
we don't
um
pressure him to get like he doesn't have
to be a straight A student we always
have always taught our kids to you know
just try your best and if that's the
best that you you can do then
as long as you tried your best we're
okay with that he's actually getting
he's actually a straight A student
um but he's he is smart he's not
um
he's not failing it's just I don't know
if the pressure of I I don't know I
don't know why he
is so afraid of his grades or having
late homework you know if he has
something that he doesn't get done in
class and he ends up having to take it
home to do homework it gives he just
worries about it
okay
and I don't know why
my guess is always been able to help
I've always been able to help him do his
homework at home and we always get it
done but like when he's at school and
it's not done he worries about it
foreign
yeah that sounds so Environmental
it sounds so environmental I I would I
would strongly recommend
um
you
you go with him
and don't ship him off to a counselor
just go send and see a counselor but you
go with him
because I think what I'm guessing is
there are some strategies inside your
home
that when he gets home there is a
there's a heightened level of tension
there and it could be from husband it
could be from
um the way he is perceiving things it
could be from you it could be from any
number of things but somehow he has
picked up his body has picked up the
and over Amplified these signals that
he's not safe
and it's going to give him a stomachache
it's going to give him a headache it's
going to give him these things right I
think seeing a counselor would be wise
because hearing it from a third party
adult
who is trained at listening and being
quiet and leaning in and making
connections with a kid
um they may even have him do his sixth
grades they may have him do some play
therapy maybe a little bit aged out of
that a little bit but maybe not
um
but another adult might be able to give
him some strategies give you some
strategies give you all some new
language together
but I'm gonna double back my guess is
this is a highly highly relational I'd
want to know if he's getting bullied at
school if school is somehow unsafe I
would really have a counselor dig into
the dyslexia and how that makes him feel
in relationship to his other classmates
um and it may be that dyslexia was part
of the diagnostic and there's more who
knows
but I want to start at home with the
things you can control and that is I'm
going to put everything away I'm going
to create space in my day and by the way
I'm not going to say I've made time for
you or I could do that
I'm just going to create space
an anxious kid is highly highly
perceptive for safety
and I want you to create as safe as
environment as possible and that's going
to come from presence so let's start
there let's get him into a counselor
um let me say it this way your kid's not
broken
he's not broken let's give him some
autonomy to make some choices about an
actor out an outdoor activity
um about does he want to do his homework
right now or do you want to do that
let's give him teach him autonomy
just teach him slowly how to do hard
things
and a good counselor is going to help
you all walk through basically
retraining his brain neurological
training for feeling that alarm go off
really loud louder than his peers
Fran still heading in
and getting those accomplishments
but screaming at him beating him up and
I know you don't do those things but
that doesn't help that doesn't that's
not a thing
and it may be time for Dad to work on
his anxiety too because there's going to
come a point if he's not there already
where your son's gonna feel responsible
for making sure Dad doesn't feel anxious
and that is a burden that no sixth
grader no kill can care
thank you so much for your calling for
loving that kid man we'll be right back
everybody's talking about how crazy
it is right now and how powerless home
buyers feel mix that with the stress of
moving and life change and job change
and you've got a tornado of anxiety
fueling one of the biggest purchases
you'll ever make this is not a good idea
so if you're a new home buyer right now
my advice to you is to focus on what you
can control like the people you choose
to help you in the home buying process
you need folks like my friends at
Churchill Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay
trusted provider that's been helping
people with their home mortgages for
decades and their home buyer Edge
program will help you skip a bunch of
the stress here's how it works apply to
become a Churchill certified home buyer
and cap your interest rate for 90 days
then you'll get a five thousand dollar
seller guarantee to help your offer
stand out so go ahead take a deep breath
because Churchill has your back check
them out at churchillmortgage.com
deloney and get the home buyer Edge
today this is a paid advertisement in
MLS ID 1591 in MLS consumeraccess.org
Equal Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane
Suite 100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027
programs are for select loan types only
and not available in all states or
locations
all right we are back hey John yes ma'am
so I was listening to that last call and
I really related with her a lot
[Laughter]
um having I like how you said that I was
listening to that let's go good because
you're producing the show I'm sorry I
was listening to this call you took
right I don't usually listen but you do
a great job glad you're listening no I
was just so kind of this is to her I'm a
few years farther down the road than she
is uh with this and some of the things
you said that really really hit that I
wanted to make sure that that she really
heard
um so you know we have a child um he's
almost 17 now and
um
Middle School was a rough go
more with Attitude not grades or
anything like that but come to find out
he first of all he was being bullied
um but
the Nathan has CP minor CP and he
struggles with some
um he struggles with some work he's got
some eye issues and there's just a few
things and the worst thing you can be at
that age is different that's right you
know and so I was at that point no he's
fine everything's fine he's going to be
in the normal classes and it's fine and
he doesn't need the IEP those who know
what that is know what it is and all I
was so adamant that he was going to be
normal quote unquote normal that I know
I did him a disservice uh and it was
when I we got him into counseling
because he was having some rage issues
and um we have chaos in our house you
talked about at the house you know with
our other child we have some chaos in
our house and so duh he had some issues
with it you know but we when we took him
to counseling and the counselor was able
to get a little hard with us about what
diff Services we were doing right to him
and then you know what these are real
legit issues and they have to be dealt
with right and how
it just it changed everything in our
house and he still goes to counseling
he's been going since the fifth grade to
the same guy and it's great because it's
someone he can talk to he's an adult
yeah an adult but you so it's important
to hear that in this particular uh
caller that young man gets headaches
right or gets stomach like he just I
don't feel good
that same manifestation that same
shaking of a snow globe your son had
rage right yes some kids shut down some
kids set things on fire some kids go get
straight A's it's that body's response
to we're not safe we gotta fix this now
and I wonder how much in your home like
the tension as you're describing that
we're gonna be normal he's going to be
in these classes that creates a
environment that his body feels like
it's got to solve because Mom is really
she's going to war for me right right
and like and so
it was
that last caller when I said hey kids
with
um dyslexia struggle with and the first
answer was
not him he's fine and I want to say oh
he's not right he knows he's different
and he knows that all of his classmates
are buzzing through these things he also
knows don't tell Mom
because that correct right so it creates
this thing what what is a way because I
struggle with this
um
maybe I need to get over it man that's
what I've signed up for
I like to be really direct and tell
people the truth but they're especially
with moms but sometimes with dads
the shame and the guilt is so
overwhelming that it's just
shuts down
um I don't think there is a way Beyond
just being direct because we have to
create a place where
where we don't take that on his shame
and guilt we just you you you use the
tools you've got you said that earlier
in a call that wasn't in his toolkit
well
until I learned you know until you learn
and then you do better gotcha but so we
have to be we have to create an
environment where
yeah it's hard to hear but now do
something about it it's and don't take
it personally it's not a shame thing
it's not you're doing it wrong so let's
try this and see if it works better you
thought a hammer was the right tool for
this it's smart when you're a hit when
you know when you're a hammer
everything's an ale gotcha and so it's
it's not shame it's just learning yeah
we're all hey she said parenting's hard
it's hard so hard it's hard that's right
um I can't think of a better alarm
system
than your kids alarm systems to
everybody listening
if your kid's bodies tell them they're
not safe somewhere listen to that and
begin take an honest assessment how is
Dad contributing to this how's Mom
contributing to this how are we can
how's our Dynamic contributing to this
is my kid getting bullied at school is
my kid not like where is this coming
from
and
let's focus Less on is this fear anxiety
let's focus more on how can we help this
young man's young daughter's bodies feel
safe
and what does that look like and it
might mean man I'm not gonna play
football this this spring
fine good grief fine
um you're gonna do something
cool I know you don't feel good when you
go to school you're going to go to
school
do you want me to drive you or do you
take the bus and if we can't that you're
going to go to school and you're going
to take the bus
um do you want me to put a note in your
lunch
or do you want me to put a note in your
back because I'm going to tell you every
day that I love you and I want you to
have this note that you can look at when
you're in school so which one of those
do you want and we're going to slowly
lean in and teach autonomy and um
it's a tough go of it I'm convinced that
over time when the kids ecosystem
becomes safe their bodies are like cool
we don't have to go to war anymore
and um man you all done must have done a
great because I've been around Nathan
he's awesome just a stuck incredible kid
man it's awesome he's a pretty good kid
we like him well
way to fix it all I didn't say we fixed
it all all right let's go to uh Breck in
St George the Utes what's up Breck
oh hey Dr John how are you I'm good man
how are you
well I'm trying to do better that's why
I'm calling I guess hey me too man me
too so what's up
so
um I have a situation in my marriage
like six months in
I I like fell back into porn and I came
forward to my wife and I explained to
her that you know this has been going on
since my teenage years and it's always
been like
you know a week on and then several
months off and you know it's been even a
couple years in between you know times
that I've fallen into it so I try to
explain it to her it's like I don't know
why you know I'm just this little rubber
band and I keep snapping back and I kind
of cut it and you know set myself free
but
um I've really connected with her and
really tried to be open and honest with
her with where I'm at but
you know with that I know that feelings
of self-image and and lack of trust kind
of start creeping in and so I'm really
struggling with like feelings of
frustration from constantly asking to
trust me and just I just feel like I'm
like spinning my wheels you know
um
so what have you what have you done
different
so
I've never I've never really had a
support person you know it's always been
like what I would tell my parents you
know growing up hey I did this and
they'd be like well
don't fix it you know so listen listen
if I'm her
there's a value
in my home that me and my brand new
husband agreed on and then my husband
came to me and said hey I violated this
value I'm coming forward I'm being
honest about it which is Noble good for
you
and then it's followed up with yeah this
has just been a thing I've been dealing
with since I was little since I was real
young and it just keeps coming back and
um I don't want it to be there but it
just keeps coming back so
all right uh don't judge me and don't
hold me accountable to it and don't get
mad at me let's go get uh some pancakes
that is very different than enough is
enough is enough
I'm gonna go join an essay group
I'm gonna go join a uh
any number of groups that meet all over
the United States
um a Celebrate Recovery Group but in any
number of things
I'm gonna go see a counselor I'm gonna
go get very serious about this
and you haven't done that which tells me
I mean you like the idea of not having
these week-long shame spirals but you
also
like the idea of having like a week-long
binge Fair
okay
I don't know I'm I'm absolutely
terrified of falling back
I know but not terrified enough to do
something
you're just sitting there being
terrified
which in a crazy twist of fate
the more wound up you are the more white
knuckling you do the more you slowly
grind off your ability to make good
decisions
and you burn the edges off and you burn
the edges off and you know what makes
everything feel better
connected relationships and you don't
have that you know a cheap substitute
for a connected relationship pornography
and so you by not being willing to go
meet with some people and say hey this
is me and I've struggled with this for a
long time
um how are you guys doing my name is
Breck I'm struggling
how are you this week Breck good I had a
good week how are you this week Brett I
I fell off man I didn't do so well or I
haven't looked at pornography but I've
been I ate four large pizzas this week
and I'm struggling with my diet like
whatever the thing is if you don't have
that your body's gonna go get it it's
going to get it in the quickest easiest
way possible
so you can say you're terrified to not
to to fall back into this thing but
you're not terrified enough to do
something
so if I'm your wife I'm just watching a
lot of lip service and then you tell me
you've been lip servicing this for a
long long time
and nothing's changed and so she's
looking at her future like well I guess
it's just going to be my marriage
and so I actually think she's right to
keep asking you or to not trust you
because you're not giving her any
alternative actions
well I mean at first when at first when
I told her you know she was very sweet
about it and and you know we we sat down
I I went to a counselor and I just kind
of tried to identify like triggers and
we set up a plan and I keep a little
note in my wallet and we have an
agreement that it was it was after a big
argument and that I just felt inadequate
that I just wanted to almost hurt myself
with it
and and so that you know our form of
dealing with that is no matter what like
if we have an argument she can just say
hey leave your phone and I'll go out of
the room and
and just kind of decompress and and sit
there and
think about and kind of cool down but
I didn't get that she'll say leave your
phone and you just leave your phone yeah
yeah at any time she just says hey leave
your phone here and so she'll I'll give
it to her and then I'll just go off and
be in her room alone and try and cool
down you know because it's it's always
been like from an argument or from like
a depressive episode that I
okay I see what you're saying so you
have a trigger
and
the trigger as you're describing it is a
it's a
fracture in a relationship
your body feels unsafe
and a way that soothes that discomfort
is pornography right
I think so yeah and dude you're not
weird
you know I mean you're not like there's
millions and millions and millions and
millions of of men and women in your
exact situation in fact what makes you
kind of weird is that you don't want to
that to be your default setting anymore
and so what I would challenge you on is
identifying the trig all you're looking
for is space here
between stimulus and response
okay
yeah
you cannot just withdraw an activity
withdraw A coping mechanism and not
establish something else in its place
addiction doesn't work like that
so you can't just pace around the house
in a minute until the urge passes
foreign
you're gonna have to go for a jog you're
gonna have to call a friend you're gonna
have to call a sponsor and get the
relational connectivity there
that makes sense yeah I just I I don't
know I feel like I've made it made
changes but what you're saying is like
that feels like it's the final kicker
and so I don't know I just have been
feeling like
almost an imposter because I'm saying
hey you know this is what happens I've
made changes and I feel like this is
where I'm at now but I don't want to
like minimize what I did and minimize it
you know the breaking values there I
just there's no sense in going backwards
dude
yeah that's you beating yourself up
and at some point
probably not just yet but at some point
your wife's gonna have to decide to stop
hedging her bets by calling this back in
calling this back in calling this back
in
because she's going to try to keep
herself safe
by keeping some moral High ground and
I'm sure she's not perfect either
and she's gonna have some this is gonna
be a way she can like a stepping stool
if you will in a raging River and it
will make her feel like she's above The
Fray a little bit it's going to keep her
safe and she's gonna have to choose to
be vulnerable again if this marriage is
going to work also
both of you are yeah but how do I how do
I ask for that you can't say that's for
her
yeah
she's gonna have to choose to open
herself up to get hurt again
just like you are
but I think you have not got radical
enough you're an alcoholic who has just
kept a few bottles of whiskey just in
case relatives come over
cut the internet off dude
get rid of your phone
get a flip phone that you can't text on
and you're going to lose friends get rid
of all social media
put blocks on get rid of it pour the
whiskey down the sink
this is what I'm talking about
yeah
and you haven't been willing to do that
which means she has to try to stay safe
and so I'm actually on her side right
now
yeah and I'm like I'm on her side too
because I sometimes I just feel like
like crap but well do something do
something
you feel like crap because you're just
you're in a you're in a you're in a
cognitive Loop man you're just in in
you're on a mental treadmill you're just
like a a a mental like mouse and a wheel
just running and you're trying to solve
it by thinking about it stop thinking go
do
go to academy this afternoon or to
Walmart or something and get a couple of
dumbbells and put them in your garage
and when you have an urge put your phone
turn it off
and then go downstairs and do 15 minutes
or 10 minutes or something
or go buy a pair of running shoes and go
for a jogged into your block
you've got to put some things some new
behaviors that are going to be positive
go to a group get somebody you can call
take action do you hear me man
yeah
take action take action take action take
action you know what to do yeah I know I
feel like that's the biggest need in my
life is I'm just kind of waiting and I
and I see that it's kind of bled into
other areas of my life I know it has I
know it has
and you think that your marriage
challenges you think your wife is
um not super into you right now because
the pornography it's not
it's because she's finding out that she
might be married to like a wet piece of
toast
right
yeah and here's what pornography gives
you can I be honest with you it makes
you feel a little bit more alive
Fair
yeah that's fair create that aliveness
in your whole life brother
you only get one shot at this thing
yeah
right
what makes you alive
go go just start rattling on top of your
head what makes you alive just being
outside okay what else you know what
else you're one of the most beautiful
parts of the United States for being
outside what else I like exercising I've
been getting into biking I just what
else we're new to the area so I just
don't have any friends I need friends
okay get there you go get them get get
him
right yeah yeah there's some weird St
George biker Club out there mountain
biker Club I know there is I know
there's probably a hundred of them
and you're gonna show up to one and
they're going to be too good you're
gonna show up to another one and it's
gonna be a bunch of like old women and
you're gonna be like probably not it's
probably not for me you're gonna find
them and they're gonna be there
and there's I guarantee you they'll
Celebrate Recovery groups in your area
guarantee
yeah go go go
you get one shot at this life man
Fair yeah
absolutely no you're like me
absolutely no go are you in yes
are you sure yes yes okay enough enough
of the well I'm just here and I just
don't want to do this anymore don't
don't make it different make it
different
make it different today you're gonna get
a note card out and you're gonna write
down for the next five days nope the
next seven days you're gonna write down
your daily routine when I wake up what
I'm gonna have for breakfast the
supplements I'm gonna take the exercise
I'm gonna get going to work the
connection I'm gonna have with my wife
the things I'm gonna do I'm gonna make
dinner I'm here's the things I'm gonna
do and no matter what no matter what
come hell or high water you're gonna
check off everything on that list you're
probably gonna add four or five things
to every list too put them on there
anyway and check them off
we are practicing a different way of
doing life
and in every one of those days every day
you're gonna do at least one thing where
you're gonna reach out and connect with
somebody else
whether that's at work it's a group of
strangers it's just going to the to the
bike rider Park I don't know what y'all
bike riders do I'm not that talented
I'll fall off and eat it I break a bone
or two
but get out and get connected
go go go my brother you're worth it and
everybody listening stop thinking about
everything so much go do
go do change your life go
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show I
guess during that last call at some
point Ben what'd I say
you only get one shot yeah did not miss
your chance to blow Opportunity Knocks
once in a lifetime you better so of
course during the break they brought me
in Eminem's classic Lose Yourself and it
goes like this
look if you had one shot or one
opportunity to seize everything you ever
wanted in one moment would you capture
it or let it slip yo his palms are
sweating these weak arms are heavy
there's vomit on his sweater already
mom's spaghetti he's nervous but on the
surface he looks calm and ready to drop
bombs but he keeps on forgetting what he
wrote down the whole crowd goes so loud
he opens his mouth but the words won't
come out he's choking how everyone's
joking now the clocks run out time's up
over wow
sometimes just gotta step back to
reality open up oh there's gravity
you got to lose yourself and the music
the moment you own it you only get one
shot America
that sounded awesome hey love you guys
see you soon